moi au départ très honnêtement j'y
croyais pas la version de carla parce
que je me disais certes elle s'est fait
extorquer de l'argent mais pourquoi il y
avait cette histoire de nuire à son
entourage est en fait ces explications
les idées très claires c'est un peu
comme un chantage à la sextape ce
qu'elle aurait vécu sert concret des
preuves embarrassante et on vient avec
ses preuves et on leur dit m voilà ça si
tu veux pas que ça sort donne moi de
l'argent
donc on ne sait pas si c'est vrai une
enquête qui est en cours et un très
jeune et trouvé très convaincant dans
ses arguments sauf qu'elle a bien
expliqué alors il ya que les oui à deux
noms on verra sur les noms dans un
instant gilles verdez aussi n'avait été
convaincu ben oui j'ai été très surpris
aussi parce que vous étiez celtique mais
très sceptique
oui elle a recoupé et j'ai vérifié au
jour des larrons super quoi exactement
toutes les informations que j'ai de
source judiciaire elle l'a dit elle même
qu'elle avait émis des chèques sur sa
holding cm holding sa société
effectivement les enquêteurs sont en
train de travailler pour abus de biens
sociaux suite à des détournements de
fonds sur cette société alors justement
nous expliquer qu'elles auraient été
escroqués par cette voyante boeing 4 au
chantage qui lui aurait coûté près de
1,2 million d'euros on aura la version
de danaher dans un instant donc voilà il
faut avoir les deux versions se love
c'est normal c'est quoi cette somme de
1,2 million d'euros ne sauriez donné à
la brillante 1,2 million d'euros il
paraît que c'est une vraie sommes sur
combien d'années à 35,4 sur quatre ans
donc sur quatre ans elle vous a extorqué
ses 1,2 million d'euros faut les avoir
déjà j'étais même arrivé au stade je me
disais quand je m'achète quelque chose
il faut surtout pas que je le montre
parce que s'ils voient que je m'achète
un sac à main ils vont se dire qu'il ya
encore de l'argent mais tout mais alors
oui oui alors j'ai été convaincu par par
carla mais en sortir de l'émission alors
on se retendent les sorties en sortir on
peut le dire monsieur emporté vous allez
voir vous allez sortir le tir de
l'émission j'ai eu des dérapages ou
téléphone d'une voyante nom qui m'a en
fait expliqué que le système de l'ours
au céleri de la sorcellerie du g2o
extérieurs était une pratique de la coi
le système de quoi la sorcellerie lors
essentielle ment et apparemment alors je
la crois de bien sûr mais c'est vous a
dit après de la voyante manic
apparemment dans le milieu des
ascenseurs le fait d'avoir recours à une
sorcellerie était une pratique courante
par exemple par exemple savez ce qu'ils
font ces nouvelles lèvres la nouvelle
eve c'est quand même un gros problème
servir bien sympa donc ce qu'elles font
alors par exemple alors pour mettre pour
pour contenir une concurrente al près de
la photo de la concurrente à le mettre
dans du papier d'alu et les mettre au
congélateur et du coup la personne est
emprisonné dans la glace
non oui absolument c'est la reine des
neiges et donc ces personnes ne peut
plus agir
et apparemment le recours à la
sorcellerie et est vraiment monnaie
courante dans ce milieu là donc c'est
pas seulement le cas d'année j'ai par
contre en parler avec elle mais
apparemment c'est je te jette un sort tu
revends instaura mal et un petit haut
rang voit pas ce qu'on tape complètement
aller à l'est la manche aller à mon cher
puisqu'elle fut gagné sur cette histoire
balma dit surtout tomber le pain on va
voir l'oeil non sur sa gauche c'est vrai
alors elle l'oeil salamero réseau la bce
nommé el al mellal mais la sauge dans la
mud ans dans la maison elle veut elle
fait des prières externe ont été
terrorisés par ça alors non elle mais
rien d'un congélateur mais mes larmes ou
très peu d'options très peur mais il ya
des hommes qui sont extrêmement que
craintif de st
sinon donc votre femme elle y croit fou
à mort dont elle dit d'ailleurs qu'on
m'a jeté un sort quoi vous apporte comme
un jeu des dogues il ya qu'il ya
quelques années je faisais ce que je
vous ai désenvoûter a totalement je fais
plaisir notamment totalement qui croient
qu'ils avaient combattus nord
moi j'étais halluciné par cette histoire
alors justement on a vu votre tête sur
aix à faire même à la tête de bernard
montiel
bah c'est pas du tout de la moquerie et
il a fait la vingtaine quand il a appris
qu'il était viré de tf1
c'est surtout pas de la moquerie sauf
que j'étais halluciné par cette histoire
elle est quand même invraisemblable
c'est abracadabrantesque qu est ce qu un
truc comme ça mais mais c'est vrai que
cette fille est touchante elle est pas
belle mais je trouve quand même qu'ils
avaient une forme de naïveté dans ce
récit qui est quand même hallucinant
alors on va voir parce que c'est vrai
qu'elle dit aussi a expliqué avoir subi
avec sa mère des menaces et avoir dû
avoir recours à des fausses factures via
son entreprise pour payer les sommes
demandées regarder on retrouve à me dire
mais je ne peux plus te payer j'ai une
société maintenant mois - au début je me
suis dit je vais pouvoir m'en sortir
parce que j'ai une société mais non car
la taille est my avait toujours une
solution mais nous on n'attaquait pas je
vais t'emmener à mon avocat mon à mon
père va te faire un contrat un contrat
bidon on condamne à te faire des
factures les factures bidon mais ça va
justifier ces paiements là en fait
c'était un engrenage vous l'avez
toujours des solutions le problème c'est
que moi je savais que je faisais quelque
chose une faute pour ma société je
savais que je faisais quelque chose de
mal mais quand on menace ta famille
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors d'aujourd'hui
quand menace tatamis ont mis ses menaces
à exécution
parce qu'ils sont allés chez ma mère ma
mère ne savait pas comment faire pour
s'en sortir qu'ils allaient jusqu'à chez
elle
oui mais madame si vous payez pas il va
vous arriver des soucis manière qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait elle a payé
alors vous avez été convaincus aussi
alors oui j'ai trouvé touchante assez
convaincante parce qu'elle dit voilà
déjà c'est pas un cas isolé on voit bien
que l'acte de la caméra et cachez donc
on sent le côté mal intentionnés de dieu
par de la voyante mais il ya quelque
chose qui me turlupine leur mémoire à
tout à l'heure
dany boon aura sa version aussi bien
quelque chose qui me turlupine quand
même ceccaldi j'ai été forcé de dire des
choses et on me demandait de l'argent
mais pourquoi ne pas avoir juste donné
l'argent et pourquoi avoir continué la
sorcellerie
pourquoi est ce qu a continué mais il a
bien compris en fait l'annoncé après les
jo samedi j'ai continué lui dire ce que
la sorcière sous-entendait que pour ses
voeux sexo et s'exauce elle devait
souhaiter du mal à son entourage sinon
ça ne marchait pas révisé voilà si tu
veux toi cartonné dans les mollets
exprimez-vous que eux le plan dans les
marseillais et l enregistrer ça selon la
version de carla et ensuite l elysée
regarde j'ai les preuves donc si tu ne
veux pas que ça sort il faut me payer
c'est la condition pour que ça marche
g berne effectivement ce pourquoi je
mets encore plus convaincu c'est que
c'est vrai les enquêteurs travaillent
vraiment sur la piste du chantage alors
été obligés de payer sont là dessus donc
quand on recoupe l'ensemble des
informations qu'elle a donnée je trouve
qu'à une vraie crédibilité à ces paroles
donc je la crois alors après c est là
une première rencontre avec dan hay et
qui sera donc je vous le dis avec nous
tout à l'heure et carla serait donc
retourner la voir et là surprise elle se
serait retrouvée face à 10 personnes
voilà qui l'aurait forcée à prononcer
certaines phrases regarde c'est moi qui
m'a parlé que j'avais envie de réussir
ta vie qui m'a parlé que j'avais envie
de gagner de l'argent
oui oui mais tu sais moi je peux
réaliser tous âges à bombay comment ben
oui je peux réaliser tout ça mais pour
ça il va falloir que tu me formule des
choses que je vais te dicter tant que je
formule est pas ce genre de change elle
ne laissait pas partir je rentre chez
moi et à ce moment même balance des
vidéos mais des vidéos d'auto personnes
dvd vidéo on peut dans ce style là qu'on
a pu déjà découvrir d'accord moi je me
dis mais moi j'ai mon nez ça je
comprends pas ainsi si tu m'a demandé ça
mais maintenant il va falloir payer au
moins je sais pas demandez ça si si mais
maintenant rappelle toi que quand tu
m'as formuler ses demandes
moi je t'ai enregistrés alors vous ne
vous a pas convaincu satie alors moi
sincèrement pas tellement convaincu la
manière dont elle parlait de cette
histoire était vraiment très très clair
mais l'histoire est quand même super
bancal et pour essayer vraiment me
renseigner j'ai du coup appelé quelques
amis et moi qui ont fait de la télé
réalité des super stars de la télé rites
et saint jean patrick gille
je suis ravi d 3 je m'appelle patrick
foulhoux de mais du coup ils m'ont tous
dit que en fait il n'était absolument
pas convaincu par sa version dans le
sang soit en fait de base car là c'est
une fille quand même pas tellement
apprécié dans le milieu de la télé
répond elle à douala à lille à la donne
alors je parle vraiment par les
candidates et l'a été je sais que la
jalousie problème avec les gens il ya eu
sûrement de la jalousie aussi mais je
sais qu'à lui énormément problème avec
les gens et que effectivement en fait
les gens étaient arrêtés ne sont pas du
tout avec carla en tout cas en tout cas
de ses projets mais explique c'était qui
explique qu'ils croient pas aussi à sa
personne gibbs
vague de soutien pour carla il y avait
même le hashtag on demandait ce qu'on
boycotte les marseillais parce que il ya
une rumeur qui avait fuité qu'on voulait
la la gommer un peu au montage donc les
téléspectateurs ont entamé boycotter la
reddition reçu des sms des captures
d'écran de l'entourage de dan et de son
assistant qui aurait relancé car là de
manière très insistante pour les
paiements les haïti alors maintenant on
est autonome on va on va les prendre
tout à l'heure cette année il sera apte
à l'heure donc ne donnait pas tout
maintenant qu'il a donc souri attendez
attendez d'avoir la tête en bas elle
vous a convaincu bah moi elle m'a
convaincu j'ai trouvé totalement naturel
pour moi elle parlait tellement vite
qu'elles pouvaient pas l'inventer enfin
je les trouvais vraiment naturel après
pour ce qu'il s'agit de du fed allait
revoir la voyante bas c'est simple en
fait la voyante a apparemment de ce
qu'elle dit c'est qu'elle lui disait ba
écoute je sors les anciennes vidéos si
tu ne reviens pas ici de dix pâtés chez
sa majesté ça qu'on a compris c'est pour
ça que ça rezaï à kevin king et son mari
sont le fiancé de carla très gentil très
sympathique s'exprimer sur les réseaux
sociaux et qui a révélé que carla et lui
allaient désormais se mettre en retrait
des réseaux sociaux regarde pas de
nouvelles pour eux avec la donc quand je
décide pas tuer un peu loin parce que je
pense que c'est la meilleure chose à
faire
on m'a calmé les réseaux sociaux si
pendant un certain temps je pense que le
moment pour ces deux essais il de se
reconstruire
parce que quand je suivis et un truc
comme ça dix kilos donc appuyé des trucs
comme ça a clairement la seule chose que
tu as envie de faire c'est de
reconstruire alors je le veux après un
kanye avait l'air vraiment attristés
vraiment pas pas par la wifi la famille
est très marquée et discuter avec un
proche du dossier qui me disait on
aurait bien aimé attaqué pour avoir été
victime de sorcellerie
il faut savoir que pourquoi toutes les
enquêtes se font sur l'escroquerie parce
qu'aujourd'hui le code pénal français ne
reconnaît plus la réaction de
sorcellerie demain n'existe plus ça
n'existe pas donc on travaille sur
l'argent nicolas pernikoff qu'on n'a pas
entendu où elle nous a pas convaincus en
fait moi elle m'a pas convaincu du tout
d'abord elle parle bien elle est
extrêmement les taux mais là où je suis
quand même très surpris mais je fais
c'est si on la tue c'est sur les
montants bien supérieurs je n'arrive pas
à croire qu'elle a pu donner un million
de moi c'est incroyable sorcière 20001
de m elle était coiffeur donc à elle à
la valeur non mais avant elle avait elle
nous l'a expliqué comment nommer elle
est là elle a une vraie valeur de
l'argent au départ mais c'est un
croisement on peut pendant des années
des années donné un million trois cent
mille euros quand vous voyez la
complexité à faire ne serait ce que des
virements de cinq ou dix mille euros
la banque vous bloque pour essayer de
massue en pourquoi vous faites des
virements pourquoi vous faites des
chèques en plus elle l'aurait fait sur
sa holding
vous savez bien qu'on est quand même en
plein dans l'abus de biens sociaux non
mais je crois elle l'a fait c'est
incroyable moi ce que j'aimerais bien
voir un c'est la preuve des montants ont
été versés à cette serre ça va c'est
quelqu'un de très important et ça me
paraît incroyable bio c'était un
investissement pour elle puisque la
voyante lui disait tu va cartonner dans
les marseillais tu vas gagner beaucoup
d'argent on sait aujourd'hui que les
influenceurs et tant mieux pour eux ils
gagnent énormément d'argent donc elle
s'est dit si je dépense vingt ou trente
mille euros par mois dans cette voyante
mais qu'elles m'ont fait gagner chez pas
50 60 70
elles continuent de dépenser maintenant
c'est l'allergie morrison ont ils mis
tout ça en place et le calcul exactement
les moins d'un million de besoins des
montants qu'elles puissent payer mais
qu'elle puisse encore gagné de l'argent
derrière messi rex et des montants sans
dire le salaire de carla les principaux
influenceurs avec les placements de
produits
le salaire démarre à cent vingt mille
euros et va jusqu'à 400 mille euros
alors essayons surtout sur la société
donc c'est des moutons énorme énorme
donc voilà donc ça fait à peu près 9 à
beaupréau en moyenne entre 50000 et 200
4 280 milles seulement par moi aussi je
vous dis ce sont des vrais montant
gilles verdez oui je les connais
également ça c'est une vraie info et
c'est vrai que gilles ne dis pas de
bêtises non ce sont ces montants l'a6
entre 120 milles et 400000 euros en
factures par mois pour des très gros
d'influenceurs voilà ça va jusqu'à 400
mille euros je vous le confirme et que
d'une aide pour ceux qui sont à dubaï ce
qui a pas d'impôt adorent exact que dr
tout l'argent des sociétés c'est du net
dans la poche ou vous gagnez deux à
trois fois plus instantanément là bas
c'est énorme
direction ça m'intéresse c'est comment
tu deviens influenceurs et bat déjà
déjà faut savoir se servir des réseaux
sociaux déjà vous allez envoyer des
cartes postales pour une question oui
vous est très suivi vous ce soir des
réseaux ces millions sur twitter à peu
près oui et à plus d'un million sur
serein sur un soir histoire de a proposé
de l'argent pour faire des placements
honnêtement à loft story à voilà oui oui
et j'en ai déjà fait un nom jamais cette
commande le faire que vous n'avez pas
besoin
oui parce que c'est que ces noms mais
pas d'une armée gens là mais voilà on va
dire la vérité pour 1 pour 1 million de
followers sur un stade
on est plutôt autour de 10 à 15000 euros
pour un emplacement pour dépendre des
taux d'engagement d'accord mais voilà
dans l'est c'est vraiment aimé ça j'ai
jamais fait mais tu vois là je vois la
rage
voilà donc nos jeux wii mais juste pour
revenir sur cette affaire à mon avis
c'est loin d'être terminé puisque
maintenant il ya encore la ferme harb
l'ata qui dit je vais vous dévoiler qui
est le corbeau qui est derrière toute
cette histoire est que vous allez voir
quand cette identité va tomber vous
allez être vraiment impressionné
impressionné sommes impressionnés par la
personne qu'est ce qui se cache derrière
tout ça la personne lui aurait dit vas-y
tu la mets la dans un trou en parlant de
carla et l'a dit qu'en cas de personnes
qui jouent au golf et il a dit oui dans
tous les camps carla va parler et bien
je parlerai juste après elle donc là il
va faire de nouvelles révélations donc
cette histoire est vraiment loin d'être
terminée alors oui non et j'aimerais
aussi ajouté que du coup la téléralité
en prendre à moi un énorme coup parce
que effectivement il ya tout le monde en
fait qui se posent des questions qui
deviennent limite parano de savoir qui a
jeté un sort sur qui du coup qui
effectivement le camp mode dans cette
histoire et surtout la grande question
est ce que carla va revenir sur des
terrains étaient plus tard alors
justement quelle est l'ambiance au
guillaume genton vous connaissez bien
voilà au sein des marseillais au sein de
la télé réalité parce que c'est vrai que
cette histoire elle fait énormément
parler on aura joué dix die tout à
l'heure la voyant qui est au coeur du
scandale qui va nous faire également des
révélations quais bas au sein des marci
mitigé il ya ceux qui défendent car là
il ya ceux qui l'accusent ce qui est sûr
c'est que quand il ya une vraie vague de
soutien envers carla elle est
extrêmement sympathique aux yeux des
gens parce que les gens pensent que
mathieu comment parler du tribunal
médiatique le temps là c'est pareil elle
a été jugée parce qu'il ya eu ces
déclarations il ya eu ces affirmations
sur twitter elle a été jugée tout de
suite il ya eu des décisions qui ont été
prises dans les épisodes la production
c'est vrai a un peu paniqué en voyant ça
il ya une vraie
vague de soutien envers carla puis on
aime bien ses personnages dans les télé
réalité c'est des jeunes femmes qui sont
victimes de situations qui les dépasse
et ça a toujours marché dans l'histoire
de la télé réalité
donc je pense que ça les rend
extrêmement sympathique et regarder
l'audience d'hier soir ça a cartonné
ça veut dire que les gens aiment car là
aussi